now joined by magnus carlson down at the
meltwater offices uh
ready for knock uh the knockout stage
magnum and the winner of the
preliminaries congratulations
thank you very much another tournament
where you score
10 and a half points in these
preliminaries that's uh
quite a high score how are you feeling
now before the quarterfinals
i'm very happy to be uh to be undefeated
and i'm happy with the the symmetry of
my score to
score plus two on each day i feel like
i've
sort of i'm starting to to perfect the
art of
getting the first seed without uh
without too much
much hassle um and in general i'm
i'm relatively happy with my play it
wasn't sparkling by
by any means but uh nevertheless i think
it was
was decent all right and of course we
have no idea who you're actually going
to face
in the quarterfinals it could be for
russia it could be rajabov
it could be levon or it could be
aryantari we saw you
talking to him before this round were
you kind of helping him are you hoping
he will make it through yeah obviously
i'm i'm hoping for
aryan then and i was just uh
telling him that he still had uh he
still had a chance and
you should just play plays normal game
in in the last round because dominguez
uh wins uh needs to win as well uh
but obviously uh regardless of what
happens in
in in the last round this has been
hugely encouraging for
fran and uh he certainly deserves
more chances in the in the tour uh after
this performance i feel um
absolutely and if it's not arya and and
also also i would
have to say prague is very very strong
um he uh he's not
you know out of sorts here uh in this in
this field
uh at all um at least my
impression is that he's already very
very strong
yeah we are seeing the game with frag
and alarezavia now do you think
uh both of these maybe is future world
champions magnus i know you said that
about alireza
um yeah i think um
everybody sort of agrees that uh is
the uh the most obvious candidate to
um to to become world champion of those
who are
um 20 and and younger um prague
i have no idea obviously he's extremely
talented but whether he will he will
break through
it's it's very very hard to say um
but i think we
we can sort of uh um enjoy the fact that
he's
uh he's playing so well at this age and
i would say also
fearlessly he certainly didn't show me
too much respect when we're
playing so he clearly believes that he
can he can compete at this level and
i think at this point that's sort of um
sort of uh enough uh let's uh
let's not talk about world championships
uh so much
for him and just let him let him develop
were you worried at any point in that
game magnus we were following it and we
thought maybe he had some small chances
yeah i thought he had some chances
he played very very accurately i felt
over
a long period there and um
but i i don't know uh
i i was just trying to
trying to to hang on at some point and i
think i did that
reasonably maybe had some chances but it
wasn't
uh i didn't feel like he missed anything
obvious
and talking about world championships
magnus it's been
a big day we know you're going to face
nepogniacci now in the world chess
championship so when you get home
tonight is it sort of
do you think you're gonna start feeling
the motivation rise
for that world championship match now
now that you know who you're gonna face
it's already happened yay fantastic dude
i mean yon has finished the candidates
one round
he's the winner one round before it is
has even finished
what does that tell us about his
strength now
no it tells us he had a very good
tournament most of all
uh and he certainly had the potential to
win
top tournaments uh for a long time and
he has
won won a couple of them and um
to to be able to show his best level at
at the candidates is very it's very
impressive
um so uh going to bed tonight is it
going to be imagining the quarterfinals
tomorrow or is it the world chess
championship match then uh i think
mostly the quarterfinals tomorrow
yeah all right thank you so much for
joining us minus good luck tomorrow
thank you